it's like sitting on a cloud oh it's not
actually a fully inflated yet read
everybody the spirit of openness I want
to let you know that this video is
sponsored by WD they reached out to us
to see if we would be interested in
making a video about their network
attached storage device called the my
cloud pro I thought this is actually a
really good opportunity to do something
a little more educational based and talk
about our secret to productivity in the
office why we're all able to just turn
out videos so fast hope you enjoy hope
you learn something and I'm going to
finish this home and reflector my
favorite box cutter this is a big ol
brick of hard right yes nice it's the
beauty of having a central spot for
ready access their data to everybody
gets to work on their own computers
you'd never have to transfer our project
it's easy to backup everything and at
the end of the day it lets you get
closer to working at your
stream-of-consciousness
meaning you think about something and
you do it and there's very little delay
between those two things which for an
artist is very very important so
according to instructions I plug it in
and I turn it on welcome 2wd my cloud PR
4100 all right next thing i do and go to
the website create administrator
password to protect against unauthorized
configuration of your my cloud system
that's it you'll receive an email from
my cloud comm with our login info holy
moly there's 20 people in 8 terabytes
available shows me how much data is on
it and everything that's pretty cool
storage my cloud get your pants yeah
cool door hats
everyone get some piping hot hat this
takes priority amigo God dang it Sam
I got everyone happy did you get it huh
or you get a head we all get maybe if
you if you want to have you don't need
if you don't need a hat don't want a hat
you don't need to have a hat if you wish
to devote your life to becoming a hat
guy come with me I'll show you make a
little haircut unicorn first take first
try so I plugged in on my cloud Pro it's
time to set it up I promise I tell you
guys a little bit about the secret to
our productivity we're able to do
everything we do so quickly because we
right here have our server all our
project files etc meaning we can have
our edit on one computer and you can
close it and go and open down another
computer or you can open After Effects
another computer and you can all work
from the same spot using the my cloud
pro I'm going to show you guys how to
set this up so after it's plugged in
it'll show up in my network and so right
here at the my cloud PR 4100
double-click on that boots up and here
we have all our folders now what you
would do if you if you're working with a
friend and you had something like this
like the my cloud pearl on your network
you access it you go to one of these
folders and you'd right-click on it and
you go to map network drive and then you
can give this folder a drive letter
let's say n for Nico and boom there we
have hit finish and that's it so now if
I go to my computer it shows up as a
hard drive on my computer under the
drive letter n meaning that if anybody
else opens up say like a premier project
everything is quick and easy and
instantly accessible from any computer
that's how you do quick collaboration
with friends now there's one thing
that's really tripped up people on this
in the past it's not showing up what's
going on it's because you have your
network set to public let me show you go
to my network and sharing Center I'm on
Windows 7 here home network I click on
that a lot of people have it set to
public network which is a problem that
usually turns off file sharing file
discovery all that kind of stuff home
network network will generally do that
it says now if you're on Windows 10 or 8
or 8.1 you go into your corner and
you'll have a network icon click on that
you'll
work things going to pop up and takes
the settings here now going to click on
your network one more time up here make
this PC discoverable turn that on do one
more thing if you pop up on your network
and your computer might say something
like hey you need to turn on file
discovery and sharing what we can do we
go change the advanced sharing options
and now we're on private current profile
and you can just make sure everything's
turned on turn on network discovery turn
on automatic sub Network etc etc just
turn a little stuff on and you're good
all right this is our going ham charity
phone when somebody goes to ham on say
the one-wheel and they dip it you have
to donate to the charity fund and Wren
since that role has been in action just
gave us our very first donation today he
didn't like how he did something very
similar to that but it involves less
balance
well should we name this jar jar binks
jar making fun beer fund Biff fun ham
bones
ham balls dude throw ball of the hammer
I'm gonna be the one putting the least
amount of money in here dude you get
some free [ __ ]
those are bail open the court of Nikko
well good thing I'm about to delete all
this footage Hey so so that my club pro
it supports Plex and basically I can do
is I can put videos on it automatically
transcode them and stream them to any
device let me just throw a file on it
and have it start playing wait to the
video is not on your phone video is not
my phone it's on the server and actually
it transcodes it live so that's like
giving me a lower bandwidth version it's
not just playing the raw file that I
copied on the server it's actually
actually transcoding it meaning I can
also go somewhere and still access the
videos on my phone pretty nerdy stuff if
you're not a nerd click away right now
you wanted to find a creative way to use
32 terabytes right in Windows you got
the command prompt you can type in
create new
one word and enter oh there goes its
writing the file so we're writing a 20
terabyte file on a twenty one pair byte
storage all the lights are blinking oh
my god it's so active right now it's
learning so you waste space right there
I've actually never seen the file a big
there's only two hundred and fifty three
gigs left how long do you think it's
gonna take I don't know it's at 81
we're see how long it takes for a 20
terabyte file to write itself to the
server here we go